vous le savez les vacances touchent à
leur fin mais heureusement il reste
encore quelques jours pour profiter est
de moments en famille mélanie poker
bonsoir qu'on soit pour votre
rendez-vous loisirs le public est
attendu pour un voyage à destination de
rambouillet et oui c'est un voyage dans
le temps et dans les jouets comme à
chaque de vacances l'équipe du musée
durant boli train vous concocte tout
plein d'animations élan pour la première
à l'accueil on va vous remettre un
livret jeu il y en a deux sortes en
fonction des âges les 3 7 ans et les 8
12 ans à travers ce petit livre vous
revivrez l'histoire ferroviaire au 19e
siècle avec un thème le temps des
machines et de jules verne
le célèbre auteur de vingt mille lieues
sous les mers et les enfants vont aussi
faire parler leur imagination
attention cette animation est proposée
sur la période que ce vendredi 21
février elle s'appelle si j'étais en
train le musée lance un défi aux
visiteurs imaginer des locomotives à
partir de trois trains qui existe déjà
mais je laisse solène la chargée
d'accueil et de médiation vous en dire
un peu plus c'est grâce au nom de ses
trains et à la description qu'on leur
donne c'est de dessiner un train pour
les plus grands d'imaginer à quoi il
pouvait ressembler et pour les plus
petits pourront coller des gommettes
donc ça c'est plutôt pour les
maternelles ils sont aidés un bien sûr
c'est un moment de partage avec les
parents ou les grandes soeurs et frères
alors mélanine question que tous les
enfants se posent et les grands enfants
comme moi se pose également
est ce qu'un petit tour de trains est
prévue et oui par contre il faut que le
temps le permettent mais solène vous
emmène en balade avec milices et le nom
de la locomotive
elle est à essence ce sont des petits
tours dans le jardin du musée pour cette
animation il faut compter 1 euro 50
en plus du droit d'entrée du musée cette
animation la a lieu le samedi 22 février
et pour ceux qui rateraient évidemment à
ces animations et bien pas d'inquiétude
les équipes ont déjà penser au prochain
rendez vous en avril et les activités
tourneront autour de l'électricité dont
les trains jouer c'est bien ça